we've already had a podcast actually I
was bad
welcome to punch-drunk sports where
winners win we are back in the studio
bill burr was interviewing a famous
drummer who was the drummer that was
Kenny Aronoff ah any good old Kenny
Aronoff that guy's a [ __ ] a legend
man you know he's in a bunch of them
he's been in set he had his own band
then he had several other bands trust me
on that he did the very famous drum beat
on Jack and Diane yeah joining us in
studio
he's quite a musician himself I even see
him on he's the wave the is it is it now
just a wave it's not the old Negro wave
yeah yeah for TV purposes yeah and you
can see him on kill Tony every Monday at
the Comedy Store and he's got great new
podcast please welcome to show chair my
walkins everybody correct oh hey guys
what's going on welcome
so I think's coming on yeah thanks for
having me uh can you tell us a little
bit about your podcast yeah so basically
it's a podcast where anybody can call in
at any time it's basically it gives a
chance for me and the guests to do
characters and impressions with each
other so we could be having a
conversation then all of a sudden like
oh I think we're gonna call and then you
know yeah who's that famous radio guy
that did all the calls on his phone Oh
they showed video of it you're like this
is insane you know Phil Hendry Phil
Hendrick yeah remember that guy I mean
they showed video of him doing it and
he's and he's like he's got phones from
the 80s like the old he's got mics all
over the place and like popping around
yeah that's awesome man what's the name
of it it's called Jeremiah wonders
Jeremiah wonders what made you want to
do that kind of podcast uh well on kill
Tony a lot of people like the the
characters that I've been doing like on
kill Tony we do different characters
every single week and we improvise
around those characters so it's a new
and different character every week and I
and I wanted to find a way to do
kind of a similar but different thing on
my own yeah I think right and there's uh
there's a segment at the end of every of
every episode of Jeremiah wonder it's
called sack stock where you tell a story
of a sexual encounter and I play sweet
sweet saxophone underneath you I super
fun sax just doesn't get the lover used
to huh no man ladies just don't bone
sacks guys anymore in the 80s but uh you
know I'm trying to make it come back
yeah I mean guitars are going away too
like they're talking about how um
everybody who makes guitars like they're
taking huge losses because nobody who's
the great good guitar hero right now I
mean I was gonna say what's a guy from
Texas the bike guy see that's what the
Texas guy I know
the Texas black guy was the Spanish
animated movie what was the name of it
no it was huge it was it was okay Coco
so guitar sales for kids spiked like
crazy after that came out because every
yeah cuz everybody all the kids saw the
little kid playing guitar and in there I
want to learn I play guitar so maybe if
there's more movies like that Gary Clark
jr. he's the guitar hero right now ah
there's a lot who's Ian Black Panther no
see that's the only one dude it's great
good yeah I love Marvel movies everyone
gets so mad cuz they're they know all
they're making are super movies well the
reason they're doing that because
they're the only movies that we know are
guaranteed to be good I mean like I mean
what was the bad Marvel flick anybody
the bad one
the first Punisher oh yeah I'm way back
in the day right you mean in the last
lucky people say yeah yeah yeah I mean
when they've been really clicking the
Fantastic Four let's just say this since
Disney bought them for dark world that
was [ __ ] yeah I find it what about the
Incredible Hulk 2008 it was that banner
when did when did Disney I normally was
at the
actually they've never gotten that right
every Hall sucked well you know why the
Hulk is getting better cuz the CGI is
getting better the spider-man where he
did like a long salsa dance in the
middle of it spider-man 2 that the
amazing spider-man 3d sucked that was
horrible okay well I I'm wrong but the
lime wrong recent spider-man is one of
the best Marvel movies there was it's
really good
well you know I'm not talking about the
2012 spider-man ii amazing spider-man I
guess like that one was not good the
second one with Garfield I don't like it
I didn't like Garfield there's new kids
great I thought they tried to make
Andrew Garfield way too cool I was like
is not cool right are you a nerd are you
comic nerd I mean I grew up like never I
really love the cartoons and everything
and I would buy comic books occasionally
but not like super comic book nerd I had
a like a like a OCD collection of like
x-men and and certain Marvel comics that
would like all the offshoots and I would
always buy one that I would read and I
would buy one I would never touch and
then when I went to college I was like I
mean I'd like you're gonna help with
[ __ ] all the way back to the 80s like I
went back to like that to like the like
early early 80s and I was like I'm not
gonna get I needed the money it sold it
for like and this is 91 I got like three
grand for that and right now it's bet
it'd be worth 20 or
all that you are like what like three
grand is [ __ ] you money at that point
[ __ ] you
I playing by your rules I don't need you
yeah three grand is life-changing when
you're 19 dude yeah yeah absolutely [ __ ]
did you ever have because I collected
like action figures more than comics oh
I have yeah yeah love dr. P baseball
cards for me I still have like a but
back in Kansas my mom has like boxes of
my brother and I it's like you actually
would have made a lot of money selling
those in 1990 there were I mean they
went down from oh yeah
no they were saturated baseball cards
aren't worth anything not reaiiy mean
they I think it's gonna take another 20
years baseball cards is it still top
shelf tops just ha tops top shelf clear
yeah I wasn't sure if that was a car
company or a fun thing you do in your
buddies hotel room when he's sleeping
take a [ __ ] in the upper deck upper deck
hey t-bone where you gonna be I will be
nowhere new episode of 92 7 the pod
comes out in about a week and a half
we're recording that this Friday and
follow me on Twitter at the teeb and you
can see where I'm doing stand-up I be in
Chicago and the June but other than that
suck it Sam all right what about ah
Jeremiah where are you you got any dates
you want to push for the kids to hear
and come and see your musical adventures
always kill Tony on Monday yes door yeah
let's kill Tony on Mondays at store I'll
be featuring for my buddy Tony
Hinchcliffe at the Sacramento punch line
all right
yeah March 1 through 3 well that's great
that's a good show it's cool you will
sleep under the bed I'm on top of the
bad day that's exactly what it's like
being on the road at Al Gore it is I did
Tony on his first road kick yeah that's
why yeah he always tells me that Sam Sam
and I did a road gig with Tony where a
girl [ __ ] herself with a popsicle so
yeah so you know hey maybe if you're
lucky the magic goes to the next
generation input what's up what in what
is this dude this is a Christian podcast
dawg I'm already okay you're about to
stick a hot dog in your ass give me a
break but it's not a popsicle oh yes so
Tevas tell me about that like is there
rules on how like deep okay yeah I mean
we're gonna discuss a lot of the lawyers
are discussing it right now there's a
team of people that are trying to figure
all that out I I'm in town I think for
the next couple weeks but my big thing
is March 25th I am doing my ass I'm
filming my special at the Viper Room two
shows seven
30 and 9:30 I'm ham picking everybody
gets in if you're a fan up I'll let you
in don't come if you're sensitive or you
think there's rules to this shed or you
know you don't think or if you're deaf
no come if you're deaf come if you're
deaf I just play the show with deaf
people and I crushed sign language
person it's pretty [ __ ] funny yeah
and they were telling me they do sign
language for anal fisting for that's how
my last album I'm not working on their
mom so it's March 25th Viper Room if you
want to go it's Sam trip just email me
Sam Tripoli live at gmail and pick it
either 7:30 or 9:30 so we'll figure out
definitely excited definitely don't send
any nudes or sign him up for any mailing
lists or anything though that is his
personal email address so definitely
don't do any of that I don't care I
don't care I just got you know what dude
I have there's a guy who's consumed
we're trolling me and we keeps making
news I got one and I just love it
what is he doing block block block boy
it's just like the time he takes to put
it in I just I appreciate it unlike
Twitter and stuff yeah I'll just Twitter
I did [ __ ] YouTube they go nuts on
you do you ever after the conspiracy
show do you ever getting good conspiracy
leads show like that like you have you
ever learned anything what do you mean I
don't know any like leaks from the
government any kind of weird [ __ ] like
that no no man I I know a lot of [ __ ]
but I'm learning not to talk about keep
it are you but keep it to myself and
then other and the rest of the clan you
know I'm saying so that's people that
want to hear about it and I get it so
I'm not gonna tell you I just learned it
she's like people don't want to hear
what you believe they just won't believe
what they want believe we all move on
apparently we live in a wonderful world
yeah and college math shapes you don't
listen people don't see that yeah okay
[Music]
to see we don't know where re is I
texted you yesterday hey what are our
sponsors is Jeremiah confirmed fight
nanny will be here I texted Ari are you
in on Skye
tomorrow the next time I talk to either
of you was when we started this podcast
no I talked to you earlier
oh you don't you know say no but I
didn't hear back from any of you and
then nanny doesn't show up so if I'm
completely out I have no clue you do
you're back out do not what sleeping
really that's how you know you're all
sleeping and I sneezed and I bum and I
just like and I just couldn't move isn't
that the word yeah it's called dying yes
slowly yeah that's just H I was saying I
threw my book we talked about in this
show before I threw my hamstring out
taking a nap I woke up with a blown out
hamstring dude lab and limping apathy I
was limping for five days something out
completely resting my body I blew out
one of your biggest muscles how do you
stretch like none I mean I stretch my go
jujitsu but what about Bo what about
like daily no I need oh so I I stretch
every day how do you but also I'm 29
yeah but but this but you're just yeah
but I do a lot of I do a lot of
pratfalls and I and I throw and thrash
my body around a lot on stage so I'll be
where if you just did at home you're
like I just I just I just
oh yeah but I stretch in the shower
every single day like while the hot
waters gone it helps like loosen up
muscles on your back guarantee you it'll
help prevent a little bit every once in
a while you know is there any chance
jujitsu played a role in this injury no
no just whose wonderful I [ __ ] love
it
so you just sneeze and blew your back
out yeah yep I'm not even like that's
God's eight hey get ready it's bumming
see how they're laughing and you and I
like wha you see Kevin I mean he's he
lost all that weight and just had a
massive heart attack who did Kevin Kevin
Smith the director really yeah yeah like
a big one the bad goat don't lose weight
well you stay if you're a fat [ __ ]
just stay there yeah stay fat [ __ ] yeah
I mean like you know and a change it up
and then you have a heart attack the
faint my favorite thing is when fat
people get thin and then
take their shirts off and they think
that they're just like it's like no dude
you're still disgusting
anybody am i right I mean you're still
disgusting almost worth of losing weight
Arielle they look worse with the skin
Aaron you by the way Aaron it's uh Mike
no I think is that true Aaron did you
see Kyle schwarber how much weight he's
lost I don't pay attention to the Cubs
baseball look this up there's a crazy
picture of this guy at spring training
last year and spring training now of how
much weight this guy's lost
I mean and of all lost a bunch of weight
and that didn't no I'm not saying that
it helped
they had a photo of him like back to
back of like spring like spring training
and then spring training where you're
just like hold it yeah that's it right
there whoa look at that you know I just
saw Bill burr I mean the guys got zero
body fat yes and I'm like dude that's it
but you're also rich as [ __ ] and you can
like all his powers go perfectly you can
pay somebody to feed you perfectly but
now you have maybe maybe even track down
a [ __ ] fly ball yeah
baseball is the one game if you can get
the right position you could be a fat
ass and make it a lot of well you know
it's weird
it's like those guys became golfers and
now golfers are also becoming athletes
yeah you know change that Tiger Woods
HGH in like a [ __ ]
unisa Oh 100 pees backed out I mean I'm
back back but he's walking down it's
actually on the on the bounce back right
now he's actually playing decent golf
for the first time in like we're back on
that sauce and hookers dude I don't know
why Nike did do that the first time be
like I'll dude we gotta get this guys
back on sandy's and prostitutes
Danny's and Pross these stats right now
let's [ __ ] do it so um so you say you
you do a bunch of our different
characters like how many characters you
think you've done and like it is every
show almost like winning Super Bowl
where you're like God take one day off
then it's back to work and you start
thinking about the next character yeah
kind of well the way we kind of do it is
sometimes we'll plan ahead of time
depending on if some event or so if a
movies coming out like it will try to
make a semi topical or whatever but
sometimes we just try to keep people
guessing and it's completely random like
last week we were cat burglars it had
nothing to do with anything but we had
like the black mass and we came out in
gloves and and the whole thing and then
it was just like we're just bad a French
kept my glasses oh sure yeah and it was
just you know you know it's silly I love
that you found like this wonderful niche
you've been able to to get into these
good high-profile shows and be able to
be artistically artistic creative you
know and I think that's pretty cool cuz
that's the same thing with the wave yeah
I mean it did I mean that definitely
that style comedy didn't really exist
before I mean it's a throwback to like
old-school comedy like with the like
pratfalls and like physical and prop oh
that with yeah with the wave so but as
far as like roast I don't wanna yeah
like that came like out of just being
organic and just like people being
around and trying to make each other
laugh and somebody that was pretty cool
is Jamar neighbors the black Andy
Kaufman like if Beatty did a story on
they wanted to do is Danny Kaufman's
story would it be the Jamar neighbors
story it could be I mean he's definitely
in that room doing this thing of like
he's definitely in that territory of
like a Robin Williams Jim Carrey Andy
Kaufman kind of character because what
he's been doing lately on stage it's
pretty fascinating he just did his
one-man show and I went to that and it
was it was great and he was a crack baby
in it we he was a crack baby that was
one of his characters one of the many he
sold things for a dollar out of a red
flower wagon to the audience members and
he wouldn't move on with the show until
people must love that dude yeah I love
that but he is uh he's on my even money
list if he blows up he's gonna
eventually at some point be running
naked down the street with a Glock like
ah [ __ ] Martin Lawrence style I feel
like he's gonna go [ __ ] it and I love
him I mean in a loving way he's he's
gonna go crazy
I could I could I could see it I don't
think he has it in him uh I could see it
I could see it and I don't mean all the
greats go crazy yeah but he like you
know he doesn't do drugs he doesn't have
all the other signs you know the
waitresses love it when he does that
naked Kermit guy wears just in like
tights oh yeah this [ __ ] black hog
highlighted [ __ ] shredded I'm like it
then I go up after him and I'm just
genetic garbage your album yeah save
triple e genetic garbage how much time
you have to spend the gym to get like
that do you know well he's got good
genes but he also goes to the gym every
day yeah he boxes do so like he he's
ripped like crazy he's got a great story
too he's a lot like Tiffany Haddish they
came from hard times and they've
overcome it and that's why I root for
them heck yeah I mean dude we've never
seen anything like Tiffany Haddish like
we've had friends blow up but not this
level I mean Rogen's his own blow-up and
that's his like own isolated blow-up
where it's like it it's this super high
level but I mean like to blow up the way
that that she's blowing up it's like
it's so impossible I was out in New York
when she hosted Saturday Night Live and
I watched from the writers room when
Marino was working on the show and it
was so surreal to watch Tiffany host SNL
a show that I've been watching my entire
life and then she tosses it over to
Taylor Swift I'm just like this is so
cool Ellen do you see her in a Oprah
yeah that was amazing dude that was
amazing I'm like this girl so has a
likable man I said this man I've known
her since she was like 18 I'm like this
girl's even money dude and she's just
blown the [ __ ] up
I [ __ ] love watching it who else do
you like that who who else do you like
that's kind of coming up I get asked it
all the time oh I wish anybody ever
would greet me my mom doesn't even greet
me like that look at that she says no
one's ever hugged me yeah
Ellen's like oh my god you're melting my
[ __ ] dead heart right now haha we're
never seen Ryan Seacrest hey you know
what same room at the same time she's it
queef queef right now you queefed your
way to the top and now you're not
Cleavon queef rental oprah my favorite
who much money on the line dawg Cory
that Queen for the [ __ ] special where
you're like I don't care anymore
yeah dude my favorite what I tell people
like be like oh you know Tiffany I was
like I've know Tiffany for a long time
like to the point where at the Comedy
Store
she couldn't get up on the potluck there
at all and the host would have her queef
on the side mic and that was her time
during potluck that that's what's so
crazy is like she couldn't even get on
the open mic the hair that's like to
show like how far she's come and like
how deserved the success is like she's
been grinding for so many years so I
mean like I don't know anybody
she was greatness beyond you know that
cat movie with she should run for
president so she wasn't even supposed to
be on what's-his-face is NBC show on the
Carmichael show yeah she wasn't supposed
to be on it the girl who got the role
couldn't do it for a day so they hired
Tiffany to Phyllis for the table read
I'm Tiffany stole it
yeah do you do everybody look to each
other like Willie there no so Willie has
because Willie's Co career the show and
I love right on the show and writer of
the show he said that he was telling
Jerrod
whenever Tiffany came in and like she
was starting to kill and he looked
around he's like she's gonna steal this
role and draw I was like nah now you're
playing man and Willie like later in the
days like she's about to steal this role
and draw like no like she's great
like and then like everybody like at the
end of the day they're like we got to
offer this to her this yeah she's so
good as a girl that they should I don't
know who's the guy that um always show
up Michelle Obama
who was the one hey who was it
Wally PIPP yeah Wally PIPP that chick is
a Wally PIPP and now that Tiffany's blow
up even more it's gotta be good I like
that should have been me Oh like I
didn't work like that but still crazy
man always show up always show up it's
kind of fun to watch man I've had my
friends have a do a lot great ship I
have a friend of mine named Ari Shaffir
I'm on a podcast well maybe he doesn't
ever do it that's a are you a special
guest host sometimes I didn't even know
if I'd say I have our friend cuz he
didn't even text me back
not only am I not on a podcast with him
we're not even friends yeah yes at least
you got a friend named or I should be
fair he could be in the jungle or
something you never know what's he
supposed to Australia like early April
or something who knows who knows man you
know I think it's really April he just
put out that special so there's two
people of my friends who've blown up
that are living the best
Ari Shaffir Leslie Jones Leslie Jones is
just doing everything she's wanted to do
like she's going to South Korea hanging
out with artistic gay people that guy's
great the dream tiba how you doing solid
everyone solid I'm excited for the
combine and a foul you guys just cut a
bunch of people Johnny
yeah we cut Coleman and Charles Johnson
Kirk Coleman and the safety in Charles
Johnson Coleman has got value Jones is
too old yeah Coleman's get another two
he slowed down a little bit and what do
you think about jano gone huh that's
been the kicker almost the entire time
you like that team Knox 17 years to
renegotiate they just like it's time to
go well I mean he was not hurt yeah yeah
he got hurt and the other great position
be a fat guy at kicker but he's holy be
a fat guy be
do you see many but do you see many fat
kickers though no but you can't you
don't see you
spelt kickers I mean Janikowski same
ones for sure no but I'm saying you you
know you can't be there like the theater
guys you're like hey I could play
football not really fat you know really
but like Genachowski was it was one
there's like they look like they like
like potato chips and have like a
six-pack every night yeah
bodies you know I mean somebody the
other day told me they don't get a lot
of red band kickers well you can be a
fat offensive lineman I mean they're
it's not just like there's one position
well of course but I'm saying we're
super that's a different kind of they're
not like fat they're like stocky you
know what I'm saying yeah yeah like
there's muscle and but you lift a lot
you know
you'd be like that guy for Kentucky the
quarterback remember him the big fat
bastard oh yeah I always wanted him to
make it friends Jared you know what I
wouldn't be surprised if that guy got
like a XFL contrast yeah I would love to
see him playing yeah and that's all you
know like as soon as I leave here I'm
just a normal person unbelievable you're
a supermodel
dude I go to some places I like I walk I
see girls turn there I'm like that
doesn't happen in LA yeah [ __ ]
monitors Angela yeah I'm a [ __ ] I'm
the creeper yeah you know we always say
you need to come visit my family with me
and go to a I have relatives in Des
Moines I will go to a Walmart with me
and des Moines Iowa dude crush you and I
watching girl supermodels go to Walmart
in Des Moines okay yeah man you go out
there like aw man so yeah he's got like
with a body like oh yeah I'm gonna tell
you he's got a lot of things that drive
me nuts
you know pro athletes with tits really
pisses me off I mean it depends on the
they the way they feed those guys in
college I mean I had a friend who played
on the football team he was a
quarterback and he was a little bit
under way and I have tits and they've
ever seen I mean I would say they
watched him eat they made him eat like
six thousand calories
I was insane the way they tried to put
weight on so you know the way they feed
these guys we expect yeah but dude no
you could work like dude you're in you
make a living or you're about to working
out there's a bench press okay
oh I see no muscle definition is what
your issues you don't get how no man
when I see heavyweights like the UFC the
farther the UFC goes from Las Vegas the
[ __ ] fatter the fighters get the more
out of shape they are yeah right they're
wearing [ __ ] like yeah they're
wearing like no fear [ __ ] board
shorts they're you know I was like they
just got done [ __ ] surfing it's like
heavyweight boxing once you get down
around 10 and lower it's all just fat
guys that's all it is is is fat dude
just dudes who could punch that's right
yeah that's Samoans dude every so solid
they can all buy in the UFC is a thick
ass dude yep and the NFL a and in Samoa
what say exactly if he could have kept a
areola Chris areola if he could have
kept his weight down he was a very great
heavyweight but he just could not keep
his weight down well you know they
always say you got to make like a
monster division but then no one would
work out a super heavyweight just
everyone would go for the fat [ __ ] title
and a fan from round two on it's
extremely boring because they have zero
cardio so it's like either our
first-round knockout or it's boring as
[ __ ]
yeah that's how you know they're not
working out I mean some Willmar well he
said he just can't stop eating
cheeseburgers that was his issue yeah
[Music]
that's amazing
hold on
I ain't talking Porto Rican like oh he
just retired
you know bald yeah I know you're talking
about the guy who's just taking money
fights at the end yeah I mean he's got
yeah okay okay one guy him I'm
completely John Molina
what weight class Oh like middleweight
usually uh yeah just fall I know you're
talking about I can't remember his name
cuz that Miguel Cotto yeah yeah
he's got that weird tribal tattoo right
does anyone have any friends anymore
were they like dude you're gonna get a
tribal tattoo see he's covered in
tattoos okay
what are you from Bakersfield look
covered great fighter hall-of-famer yeah
great great okay okay the already
doesn't change everything okay I'm just
saying I'm just saying that I dude when
I see a guy that looks like a comic book
walking to the [ __ ] Octagon Mike
Tyson had a tattoo on his face not too
much later much later and a tribal
tattoo on his face you guys have any
tats I do
I don't what do you got my sister and I
have the same tattoo let's go which is
in different parts of our body because
of different reasons but I does ohm
symbol on my left shoulder you want
symbol of ohm oh nice she has it on the
right ankle okay you just got a new one
I got a new one I got bank's Keys Bane
sees Bane sees just assume I'm saying it
wrong okay
ah my brain is built weird I know a lot
but I can't pronounce any of it but oh
thanks key here okay I got the Panda the
gun can we see it here we go
this is exciting yeah yeah yeah it's
exciting
oh yeah yeah great I love that you've
had that a while I mean it's healed up
then you got crimefighter
I got crying fire that was my first
album and then I got I'm gonna get one
more it says Ronin don't need any more
you've really adopted that I saw a guy I
saw a guy with and I swear this is true
maybe I said on this ship before one of
those guys that like you know Josh no I
mean my brother and sister do good yeah
well they have my brother has barbed
wire on his on his left arm I think and
then he just got some Latin Conor
McGregor has a lot covered in tattoos
covered
no he's got a lot of tattoos I'm just
saying it's not 100%
it's not even 80% I'm sure you can go in
like a minute come on okay I saw a guy
that like you know one of those like you
say like comic book like he's just
covered in tats in Venice Beach and he
had a tattoo where your mustache would
go which is a don't move if it's gonna
be like a mustache like that'd be great
that just said [ __ ] eater
yeah what are you doing ruining every
Christmas ruining every Thanksgiving hey
honey where are we putting your cousin
[ __ ] eater yeah uh at Thanksgiving
cause if you sit by Grandma she's gonna
die I mean Lucy eater you've done yeah
Takei I gotta be like you got to sign
this waiver because you're about to ruin
your life what kind of girlfriend do you
get with a tattoo like [ __ ] eaters
they're like [ __ ] yeah but like is she
like looking down at him like you know
what you're goddamn right you gotta see
this you always happy [ __ ] you just
yeah you can never really get out you
know where you get out your system and
you're like I've had enough of what a
dumb [ __ ] yeah you had ladies like you
so you want to go down on me tonight are
you look at you have to like uh what do
I feel like doing tonight
yeah I mean like I just kept this one
when he got to the bone it hurts so bad
it was like someone just stabbing you
let's really take my necklace it's all
the it's all the the ridge really I have
a couple of that I want to get but I
really my next tattoo and I'm not joking
is going to be the word tattoo but in
like a tattoo we kind of a font you know
a - I would tell you get that somewhere
you can't see it cuz that's gonna be
forehead no I was going for her you
might as well get a tattoo of the word
Metta on your body
dude that's a meditative for some people
like oh now you don't need to do that
dirty done as a friend said friendship
don't oh it's done deal okay already
paid for it
I just Gary paid for it yeah layaway
yeah you would dream of the down pat to
tattoo I mean while everybody was busy
investing in Bitcoin I invested in the
tattoo tattoo hello hello Mac so what's
going on bitcoin is still killing it at
ten thousand but it went down a little
bit but now it's half of what wasn't
much good but it's still good why why
did he go down well it was a little bit
of a bubble I think it went mmm
are we really talking about [ __ ] get
financial on this [ __ ] shot so uh you
are a regular commie store yes and you
how long have you been a regular since
September of 2016 which I'm gonna say
something man it's really hard to get in
there now really hard it's almost
impossible I think you just made it
before the no more white guys roll yeah
we'll see I mean yeah I mean I I
showcased it took me a third time before
I got passed which is hilarious because
because that is seems like a lot I went
five times and I think are you went 48
times I'm crazy but weren't you guys
showcasing way more frequently weren't
you doing like once a month or whatever
because like team and I we have to wait
once he I waited seven years yeah
I waited seven years yeah between my
first showcase and my second one because
Tommy refused to showcase he just says
he should wave a magic wand over whoever
bought him pop I remember when was that
one dudes name he's a comic but like he
was Tommy's weed dealer well there's a
couple guys there's burger that's that
guy and then there was burners on stage
and he's like getting like good spots
and all this sort of [ __ ] and Polly
comes in and stood by
the cover booth determine egos did is
there a drug dealer on my stage
yeah never got another spot again oh I
remember that night mm-hmm
when do because they switched out the
MCS that night where exactly I was I was
at potluck in the and I was watching and
Polly showed up I didn't know what was
going on but Berger they he either left
or something and somebody had to replace
him as emcee that night which was very
strange I don't know yeah but like me is
just like that was whenever I was like
doing the Pollak I was like what is
happening why is somebody being replaced
as emcee like right in the middle of the
show mm-hmm Berger used to talk a lot of
[ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] James Berger yeah I
mean like Doody he's got the most famous
there's two famous yelp reviews there
one is about Berger about how he was
bombing on stage the other Dave Taylor
yeah I guess yeah
Berger was the first comedian that I saw
The Comedy Store whenever I first went
there
oh my god that was horrible am i seeing
a friend show and worse like a regular
that I saw me first paid regular I was
freeze love and you're good
remember who the first person I saw was
freeze love and then Johnny Sanchez and
then Eddie Griffin all three of those
were back to back to back first person
tonight with this drive brought up as a
paid regular right after my first set
was earthquake oh I like earthquake made
a nice guy yeah very nice guy yeah
rhythm he goes right following that guy
you better [ __ ] mmm later story okay
big announcement punch trunk
announcement I was at the store met a
guy who knows me from calling in to the
horn 90 and your love probably but I met
she has a boyfriend
but uh she knows he this guy knows me
from calling into the horn and that that
you did you've been there in Austin
there from Austin talking to her and she
goes he's like yeah he does a podcast
punchiest
oh you're
trunk ladies and gentlemen we found our
third female fan yes she's heard of us
she's I don't think she's ever listened
to the show her name is Katie from
Austin I don't think she's ever but she
has heard of us that counts that's that
counts as a female fit on our way dude
we're on our watch three once you get in
their chat boards [ __ ] starts patch
three out of 40,000 females so if in
that include thousand that includes many
more females than that that includes Mac
hard he just means in the United States
no no I mean a people that listen to
this show regularly okay three of those
people are female
boy I mean maybe she'll listen
but she's heard of us yeah that counts
that means something that really does
that means something for sure it is
weird when you're in a some place in
somebody just comes up go I love the
show it's like it's still surreal - well
I can recognize punch-drunk fans when
they're coming up they all look exactly
the same but when a sec wonders yes
future sex offenders they're too young
to really get into their filth but
they're filthy they're filth is coming
out but when it's a girl you'll just I
was taken aback some I was like oh wow
pearls stage play in England a lot of
people think we're that on Twitter or
what oh yeah yeah there's a product or
production group in London called dance
punch art and we always get these like
I've never seen this yeah they're called
punch-drunk and uh let's fight them
let's challenge them I'd rather fight
them than the starting a kid I know
they're getting it first fighter and the
kid are getting it first
they're the reason we don't have
punch-drunk calm these bastards I'll
tell you this okay you come in lead-in
with your face well you you get you know
that yeah but these guys maybe we can
tune up with these [ __ ] idiots
oh yeah punch trunk I challenge these
guys to a fistfight how many other five
six seven probably uh probably thirty I
fight theater dorks I'm not even gonna
different sexuality and I'm gonna invite
international version to you so Oh
Fight Club together unless unless
they're Samoan I'm in or
african-american we shall accept your
challenge we are seated
I'm sorry t-bo production have you not
seen sleeping them is always white shot
great movie
great movie yeah that's it I bet you
love their gonna black eyes wide shut
when I'm done with these idiots Hey
punch shrunk in England I challenge your
idiot [ __ ] acting group to a
fistfight I'm sorry we cannot accept
your challenge Jason you Americans are
so barbaric got you anyway my accent you
at Ari it's just garbage you and Ari
just chill would you guys throat kick
every one of these guys aren't y'all
keep saying guys but it's only one guy
one guy in a bunch checks which is why I
think you want to fight that prepared to
beat of course looks like we're gonna
fight every acting group looks like I
with a half a face in you take out the
[ __ ] lead dog you beat you just walk
up punch the guy in the [ __ ] throat
and then you just make gorilla noises
and all the girls just scatter and run
and we now are the only punch-drunk
getting your throat punched idiot
prepare to be teabag Jason hey now I
think there's actually other actual
teabags Wow let's have a cup because I
think those guys can actually fight
which guys I think there's no boxing
right he can find Sam you got to have
that attitude you do I do
but old [ __ ] like strip-mall one from
[ __ ] early 90s yes can you step on it
for three years you seem like the high
kicks yeah I mean I don't know if I mean
I would have to stretch a lot to like a
like every day the door frame I mean I
could probably you know kick that light
out what's from here a basketball okay
Patrick prior to your dad
I swear to Christ that's another throat
kick coming how long these guys these
guys sell shoes yeah they're about to
get that look like soccer
gypsy fighters it look like all ex rugby
players yeah what shipped to smoke
daddy's coming - chiptunes talking -
yeah like those guys from that
documentary fist about those Irish
traveling people yeah the gypsies guys
actually thought Mickey hadn't had a
chance all right
all of them that's what Tyson Fury is
he's one of these guys he is a gypsy
right you are right yeah speaking of
fights if you'd like to get your art if
you like going to seeing live events
whether it's a kill Tony in your in your
city or a a major boxing event cuz we
wanna go see power what about a little
something coming up called the
n-c-double-a tournament ah dude we gotta
go this year gonna go for different
cities as a great way you can get
tickets to that I'm going tomorrow night
to see the Clippers take on Houston
because this was after the big fight in
the locker room and then they traded
everybody so it's meaningless but I
really I mean we're gonna run of our
lives so you got a C key right they've
made it so easy now to get tickets it's
unbelievable go to see key look at click
on the Rockets over there click at the
rock boom right 30 bucks enough if you'd
like to join Sam Tripoli yeah I mean I
paid a little more now I don't want $20
but it tells you what what tickets are
good deals what tickets yeah are
overpriced and it's a great app to have
in your phone cuz no matter where you
are let's say you're traveling let's say
you're in New York or you're in Miami
you're like what bands are around me
right now what events can I go to
it recognizes where you are and it tells
you every event that's happening and how
much you you know is after you buy a
ticket and you look later and see that
somebody else is getting the same ticket
for less I hate it yeah plus there's no
hidden fees no hidden costs no surprises
there's no all that other [ __ ] that
you have to pay with other people go to
see geek.com yeah yeah download the app
and
then put in the code part oh yeah is it
special
oh yeah it's Punch yeah punch hook and
that gets you 20 bucks off of your first
ticket to you by you right here clipper
ticket 28 bucks this is a good punch oh
that's an $8 ticket because everybody
thought was gonna be a crazy thing so
they well bought two tickets and then
they traded everybody they traded Blake
they traded
yeah but Sam it's still a very important
game it's a great thing about being a
hornet slippers can pull that off
oh you're like one game out of yeah last
spot yeah they're like three games out
of the third spot or some [ __ ] it's
crazy how what bless is really gonna
come down to the photo finish as they
say I'm gonna say right here huh I mean
it's gonna be hard for LeBron to make it
to the finals this year I know the East
is uh watered down but I think Boston
will get back together it's gonna be
real hard man I was taking about two
weeks ago I was saying two weeks ago
that I was like uh because I was still
so mad about the Blake thing you know
that then I'm like [ __ ] MBA [ __ ] the
MBA I'm slowly kind of getting my I'm
licking my wounds and I'm kind of like
because it's the East is getting
exciting and the West is really exciting
I'm okay see like a murdered but my
problem is this my promise is like we
know what's gonna happen we know what's
gonna happen I dude I'm gonna tell you
this right now
Golden State is gonna have a really hard
fight against Houston but one of those
two teams wins the NBA yeah that's a
sure we know what's gonna happen we are
sure we know that what do you want what
do you think would happen to Chris Paul
and LeBron James's friendship if they
went to the finals and like won one beat
the other one I mean our Chris Paul and
LeBron like super titers and oh yeah
super time I don't think anything would
happen yeah I think they is doing
nothing
it would be no drama yeah they like I
have a dream and you just crushed it my
sole job bro bro maybe not brother nice
job nice job and they high-five each
other then banana boat emojis yeah there
are professionals all right
did you guys grow up playing basketball
yes I love ya because I play basketball
like junior high I played against you in
the league and you know ya play I play
played in the comedian league yeah
started the open michael jordan i played
defense oh did you that was a successful
team for a man yeah i have started it
printed the jerseys named it you know
what's so funny is that they added like
four new teams because it was such a
waiting list to get in yeah
so crisper so me so they were like hey
here's a matt noce was like here's a
list of all these people that want to be
in the league you know so we kind of did
like a almost like a draft sort of like
oh yeah but me i go give me a give me
all the black guys literally what I did
says like Kareem Matthews and I got his
people then with the creams like hey man
my buddies I open my car and he's like
he played for Hawaii he's like seven
foot one his dad played for the
Milwaukee Bucks
so then drafted drafted draft so then
it's like you know and like so everyone
had all these matching you know we are
like we really like the Bad News Bears
but all the sudden we start you know
like half my team can dunk you know I
mean like and then noce was like hey man
everybody's sending me emails and you're
like you and Glassman ruined the leak
they want you to you have to send us
like flyers or proof that these people
are actually comics got a raise a
material all the black shows you know
like the J spot and all these places
that no one wouldn't didn't they didn't
know these guys yeah something a man can
you guys send me flowers they didn't I
got ringers I mean like glass thing
totally got ringers he got that kid who
played for Florida yeah day he got
ringers that weren't even doing stand-up
everybody that was on my thing was like
cause Cory Matthews who I love he's been
on the show a bunch times he's like hey
man I know a bunch of like you know like
people that like to play ball they're
like comics they aren't in this circle
and I'm like if they're good get them if
they're good get them any funny black
guys just bring them on little Oh what
about Willie
these are totally chats with them
holding a mic
Hunter no no the all that you can dunk
he like your height telly Mac yeah oh my
god just and it doesn't even running
standing with the ball can jump straight
up and two-hand dunk without a running
start at all genetic super freak and
he's like your height where do you guys
play Center championships I had nothing
more the proof you're like a shooter
right you just stay on the offensive
well and recreation are blinded down low
guy I went down low and I would like I
would be an atom Ray would just go at it
full quarter half court referees
everything and these were during my coke
days too so I was really wanted so I was
like an old-school father halftime blow
and half time I would try cigarettes
dude some of the industry that play take
it way to series yeah they take
everything too serious to do they would
throw my guys faces yeah those like it
was like that with the business school
players in college they would come out
just destroy everybody like take a
charge yeah exactly like flopping yeah
real game black bean belt blackballed
like one time they're like dude those
guys are comics I'm like well yeah they
are dude and they're like it was like it
was mal halls brothers came the player
adapter can shoot the lights out - and
now Hall can hit he's like in that
couple years of that league that we were
all in he was basically like the Steph
Curry like he's a dude that would hit
like 11 threes in one game I don't know
I think he was more of a driver he liked
to drive he was great at bat he was a
physical he is a physical specimen well
he was an open Michael Jordan I saw
wealthy yeah I had him and I had cream
Matthew oh we grabbed him
yeah yeah and then you guys got him the
next year you guys how does that work
whatever team Moses was on was gonna
suck every your own team everybody Moses
would have never had a good team yep
he was yep I'm like dude but he also is
like happiest is [ __ ] about it too he's
again okay yeah yeah yeah you got beat
by 47 yeah it's only halftime yeah
that's interesting dude he's he's such a
Zen guy right I've only seen him get mad
watch he touches my dick more than I
touched my dick every time I see him he
just grabs me by the deck
I like that so does your dick sit big my
dick [ __ ] Turtles up dawg that's like
depends on the temperature my dick is
like always in fight mode I can't be
having people grabbing my dicks
multiples I mean it's got gravity like
are you show or grower I think are you
suggesting don't work I'm I'm a grower
for sure I'm a grower for sure my shirt
just like I'm bold thank God my dick is
a puffer fish just sits there quietly
and then some touch boom it goes action
Jackson I'm beat it's poison now yeah I
think it might say you're both I think
so sometimes you can't be can you be
both I mean you can be like you can sit
you can sit be sitting well and then
show or can be a grower yeah if you're a
show or then you're halfway through
showing and growing you're like I'm not
all the way it's kind of yeah yeah
that's good yeah I would say that's it
that's a good place to be I run cold
down there yeah me too dude my shits
like dude nobody's gonna tap like like
if I had to do one of those things where
we all lined up and just drop trou
I would I would not want to do that
always ready to go you're one of those
guys the conversation is actually you
can't still have to go through showers
like that what like we did in school man
I used to have to spread by a sheet into
the boys school always have a pedophile
that would show way to zero dude said it
got blown past
he said he'd spread as much
to make sure he wasn't smuggling
something to his boys school like that
they probably thought he was a crackhead
how skinny he's got cracking I could
whole Star Wars lunchbox into my ass all
filled with heroin you know what I used
to do now is seven I used to uh steal
nudie mags from where from the
convenience store okay and sell them at
school or what man you've I've always
been a hustler like town bar subscribe
box whatever man when you're like when
you're a kid five bucks that's why you
remember when you're a kid your
grandparents would send you like here's
$30 for lunch money you're like oh
you're a kid you don't give a [ __ ] now I
need that money dude and they're dead I
would sew video games and pokemon cards
oh really oh I ran scams back yeah I was
scandalous yeah yeah in college I used
to sell used golf clubs on eBay back
when you baby was first time oh this
guy's a [ __ ] he's a dude some dudes
get mail to his house he's selling his
mail guys selling his mail on eBay when
I was in college I guess the guy who
lived in the apartment before me was in
the Illuminati because he gets his
magazine I've never heard of the inserts
inside it's all just like million dollar
cars dresses that nobody can afford and
the interiors are giftcard it's like
$500 gift cards to these leather makers
and [ __ ] like that at some sort of shift
I just sell them on eBay that's great
for like half off or whatever well yeah
like 200 bucks cost me nothing straight
cash homie straight [ __ ] should have
filed the change of address form [ __ ]
mouthful it's probably dead
with my grandparents yeah you don't send
me Christmas cards [ __ ] you Tom Jenkins
[ __ ] you Tom [ __ ] [ __ ] that sounds
like a shady fake name so hey I'm Tom
Jenkins I'm like oh so you're undercover
cuz it is a fake yeah hi I'm John
Johnson I'm Steve Steve err soon or how
about someone who's like who's like
their last name is dick and they named
their kid Harry it's like what are you
doin dude I
how do you doing whose last name is dick
when I was like people Andy Dick is the
only one I can think about anything
that's is realized according your timing
he thought of one right away I think
that's the only one with hairy dick when
I I swear I'm not when I was a kid there
was a girl in my school whose last name
was salt su LT her middle name was Anne
take a guess at her first name pepper
and salt there you go I mean you're
torturing this Harry does Harry Dick was
a Canadian professional ice hockey
player played 12 games in the NHL right
there was a guy in NASCAR named Dick
Trickle oh come on man so the real names
are Richard but they go by dick because
they think it's funny right who names
who looks at their child this amazing
amazing thing that just happened the
universe goes and your name will be dick
what about Dick Whitman huh why say what
name their kids dick
it's rue the shitty name it's like you
your name is dick and you shall get your
ass kicked in high school my college
roommates yes my college roommates name
was boner Cummings and like who names a
kid boner my Aunt Bea was was your
roommate gonna be coming Devo was your
roommate you yes it was you know dude I
new girl earn it was vag and her last
name was tastic crazy wild is growing
college I mean names are changing though
you remember back in the day now they're
all stripper names like everyone's like
Anastasia and nobody cares about
spelling anymore like [ __ ] spelling yeah
anyway you want us best phonetic almost
all the spelling example if you're a
comic can you still do jokes about how
black people name the kids weird you're
a hack because white people are just
blowing black people out of the water I
mean it is just getting ridiculous
hmm doing my sister than name their kid
river see down skin like that you know
like I like the black angle more
whispers not that bad like shampoo
that's a
black name I haven't met a shampoo yet
but there's got to be a shampooed
Jackson somewhere fucking's circle in a
stripper pole Oh have you seen the video
of the strippers praying oh yeah I love
oh my god there it has to be fake it's
not funny it's real I think it's real I
mean she's crammed with hookers why
would he love strippers you know he ran
with a hooker I'm pretty positive Jesus
was a full-blown gay man and I'm willing
to say that live on this show and if
anybody has a problem or terrorists want
to attack us or Isis wants a piece of us
you come find us
me and Sam Tripoli are not afraid of
Isis I am challenging you want some Isis
see I think but the guy with the camera
it gets that it's funny because he's
like brought a camera on their ass have
you heard this they must do it every day
how they must these strippers praying
before they play for the beginning you
ever watch that movie with Jamie Foxx
the player emac I just say some to all
the strippers in the world ass implants
aren't sexy they don't look good and it
just it's just like you're killing my
boner here like breast implants wait you
like black strippers are you sure Graham
Raiders so it's like my basically my my
Instagram is basically Compton by the
airport where that Magic Johnson is you
know in this and the Starbucks where
it's like grassy black
that's my Instagram it's nothing about
classy black if you only follow like
strippers and stuff on Instagram it
doesn't get you like too worked up
during the day if you're just scrolling
and you're just like I don't know like I
feel like I just follow Olivia Munn
that's enough she's got the hottest
friends at shake it song I bet she does
nothing but hot chick I bet she'd be fun
oh yeah I recommend no she seems rad
probably got tired of pegging uh Aaron
Rodgers in the ass
yeah take that Aaron Rodgers you visited
a bunch drunk and I said yeah why should
I Isis listen to me if you want a piece
of us Aaron is here every single day
Aaron everyday right yes he said yes his
mic is off Sam like you wouldn't let her
beg you in the asking me no I know I'm
an I'm a straight exit homeboy okay
nothing goes in if she wanted to I love
that prostate exam I'm four I'm 40 I'm
in my fortune I should got a bunch done
by now but now you're playing with fire
I am maybe we can do that while you're
getting the hot dog up your ass do you
think we could just get a dog just get a
doctor in there I love have him I love I
love that two-for-one deal yeah I love
galloons Joker he's like my wife wants
me to put once to put something in my
ass other than or
and I'm like maybe both fish but that's
it he's a great writer maybe is right
maybe both right but that's it he is a
great right he's brilliant
I best I enjoy his comedy there's a
couple guys there I really enjoy you
know Fahim is fun to watch
who do you guys it's great store besides
me I was thank you and now I'm pretty
much tapped out I get it I get it I get
it
Eric Griffin I always enjoy watching
just perform so as Bobby is the Bobby's
the most consistent deformer I've ever
seen favorite comics of all time yeah
aside Sam
besides Sam Tripoli well as far as
stand-ups go Steve Martin and Jim Carrey
for sure we're talking comedians in
general throw Chris Farley in the mix
and those are my top three you think
that's really physical yeah
now has it been in what have you learned
from being at The Comedy Store huh man
like has it forced you so much because
you were doing kind of uh you were
always very funny but you were doing
kind of your own little thing and you
did that really cool thing where you
like you played a robot I think I was in
Stephen Glickman show where you were
like yeah I did I have a bit where I do
approve it's a pre-recorded bit so I'm
basically the lip-syncing my own bit and
there's music and there's just like some
different like canned audience laughter
and different stuff like that would you
say you're the white Jamar neighbors who
by the way is gonna go crazy it's even
money that he goes crazy so that it's
even money that you go crazy no I
wouldn't look I would say you know what
somebody recently said about Jamar and I
was another comic and this was a huge
compliment to us they watch guys [ __ ] no
outside of that they said that our
chemistry because Jamar and I work on
stage a lot together is is like
reminiscent of like a prior Richard
Pryor Gene Wilder kind of thing well
they're both like out there and physical
but they complement each other yeah but
they're
not but they're also the approach is
different yeah for sure for sure you got
that Iowa angle he's got that confident
there's no straight man yeah they're you
know right exactly yeah Willie Willie
that's what's great about the wave is
Willie plays the straight man a lot of
times whenever we are the three of us go
on stage he's like helping set it up or
which is weird for how gay he is
does anybody anybody have a better
haircut then Willie hunter that flattop
is I was telling ya I got more the Vaz
the Vaz I'm sorry he needs to carve it
into the likes does like cityscape like
the sort of looks like Los Angeles all
cars there's a Barbara that could do
that
there's a black of course they're
amazing they're amazing we try to get
one on the naughty show to do a
Decepticon logo into my adult film star
friends Bush and they're like ah we do
it but it's different here it won't work
we're like really thinking outside the
box what is it what if they change come
on gold get gold you are bloody you
throw it around and it comes back and
you catch it and you give it to the kids
white hair you can do anything with
white hair Asians got good hair too they
have great hair good yeah but they only
like to do - looks Bowl cup or Dragon
Ball Z I think it's hard to style their
from understanding that goes everything
I might be stepping outside of the lines
here guys but I'm gonna go on a limb and
say Asians are ridiculous and we should
get rid of all of them is that racist no
that's just political and we don't work
political and half the planet the new of
name of same Tripoli's new album I love
black chicks and I love black strippers
it's a working title right it's so so
you get in the Comedy Store you got
these kind of set pieces and it's would
you say your act then was a little more
abstract maybe and then the Comedy Store
you kind of like that oh are
is a crazy [ __ ] and it's a dojo
and you got to learn some stuff and it's
kind of like taught you to take that and
work it within the comedy store style
maybe I think the main thing of the
comedy store that has kind of taught me
I've always been loose with my act but
with a comedy store depending on what
time you go up it the the room the oh
the original room is constantly changing
so something like just the other night
like I was I plan on doing a 15-minute
set of material like I was planning on
doing a certain thing and then I felt
this shift that whenever I just rift a
little bit with the crowd that they were
like they wanted interaction and I
bailed on the rest of my set and it
worked really well cor will force you to
do that sometimes you have to it I think
the comedy store forces you to be very
present with whatever room that you're
in in comedy I also believe that the the
magic of the or is that the lineups are
insane and there's no host so whoever
just annihilated or crash and burn you
have to walk right into that yeah yeah
it's also it's it's also pushed me to
just try as many different forms of
comedy as possible there is a blessing
going up late at the in the or now
because it's the only place you could
work on [ __ ] totally unless you're a
rogue in that he can do whatever the
[ __ ] he wants but if you're on that
level but I really just think it's like
Rogen and maybe one or two like Bill
burr that can do that I everybody else I
see they're just everybody's just going
for blood I mean I did a set like I I
most of the sets that I do are very
different set to set and the or but I
did a set recently where I said I said
two words the entire 15 minutes and then
the rest was there was music behind me
and I was like just miming and like
doing act outs and stuff like that like
with piano behind me I love it
and I'd literally said two words in 15
minutes so and how'd it go it went over
really well because it was it was those
things where people were watching and
they're just
like what's gonna happen next a is he
going to say something and then also I
haven't seen anything like this so I'm
going I'm gonna give this a chance
because I committing so hard to it that
I was like just follow me on this
journey you know no for you know the
last person I saw do that was Adam Rae
would do that a lot but he'd like do
these characters on stage we haven't
seen that for remember when Paulie
brought in the jerk the German version
of Pauly Shore do you remember that
Tebow think you got the hair yeah yeah
yeah he's like I'm the polly shark
Germany that's how that's how you tell
everybody that when you mad at me think
I'm nepali short germany and he go up
with this which is like saying like I'm
the Donald Trump of Denver was it was he
was he just playing character or was he
like seriously popular in Germany he was
really really popular I was very uh
and it was all music used and it was fun
the watch I enjoyed it but you know
Elly's weird man if you're a big fish in
another place sometimes people don't
want to stay here that long
it's much easier to go back to wherever
you are and commies it's like comedy
isn't the best place and the weirdest
place right now like there's so much
opportunity in terms of creation of like
content but I feel like in LA like this
the sets are stuff it's like I just I
don't there's no law sets out there like
there used to I used to be like three or
four-day maybe I was younger and I was
hustling more I got three in the other
day well there's also I mean if you go
to open mics in Los Angeles was which if
I don't have a show I'll still go to
open mics around LA dude
the amount of comics right now like it's
it's crazy how many comics are in Los
Angeles right now pursuing common right
so it's it's super oversaturated right
now it's so very very oversaturated so
we're just in that boom right now like
you see what's going on with like the
Renaissance of the store like with all
everybody who's coming back and all the
shows or like sold out most of the
nights of the week we're gonna like this
this comedy boom right now and it'll be
interesting who actually sticks around
after that bubble pops what are the guys
you're seeing they're starting out what
are the influences on them
Johnny what what would you say their
style is what were they influenced what
do you mean a lot of physical stuff or
is it more I mean who I like borough I
would think would be really big bird
Rogan CK was a huge impact on a lot of
comics for years especially you go to
the open mic scene and it and you would
see people doing a bad impression of
what they thought Louie CK would be
writing yeah yeah yeah and then it goes
in waves like five years ago everybody
was doing trying to do alt comedy where
they're just literally just standing at
the mic and just like trying to be like
kind of clever not like no punch that
was a big thing
no punchlines and comics get called old
school if they had punchlines or they
called a club comic if there if there is
like hard punch lines which is so yeah
it's very interesting and you would see
there's a guy named Alf and he was good
he was trying to become the town book
off Lamont if you want to harass him
online great guy but he kept trying to
bring the UCB guys to the Comedy Store
and it just wouldn't go well well I
remember he would be like hey what we
should do in the belly room is like
let's have a trivia night and I'm like
this isn't a bar man yeah this is a
goddamn comedy club and if I'm gonna
MIDI if you're gonna do if you're gonna
take twelve mobs away on a Wednesday to
have trivia night to sell Bud Light [ __ ]
that yeah it was it was crazy man
and you know why because people don't
realize yes the Comedy Store is the
mecca of comedy I think everybody will
agree with that it's the mecca everyone
will agree right yes but what makes that
room so amazing is that you get this
mixture of LA and all these people who
are staying in these hotels then a row
that are just it's like playing Middle
America sometimes and it's like if
you're playing some hipster bar all the
time you're not gonna get those peoples
right you got to have that blend of
everything you know yeah and that's why
that place is so unique compared to
anywhere else it's just like they have
like five hotels around them and those
hotels packed up
and then everybody on their podcast
talks about like we are now and it
becomes a destination oh we gotta go to
Comedy Store one night yeah we just had
people last week who came from London to
check out kill Tony on Monday I was one
time I was at the store and I was
arguing with Bret Ernst oh that's never
happened that never happen to anybody
we're arguing about who knows what
football or politics or anything he's
such a contrarian and I was arguing in
such a loud way that was I got a little
red state on it you know Devine where
the voice gets growly and I'm angry and
when I'm doing that this guy from over
here turns around and he's like are you
T and I go what do I owe you money like
[ __ ] your girlfriend like what's going
on right now you think I [ __ ]
recognize your voice you know you're
like he recognized the sound of me
having a meltdown is that crazy from
another country from the other side of
the planet and as I recognized because
that's crazy and it's people like that
wouldn't be at the store if it wasn't
for podcasts sure 100 odd cast started
and all of us changed the game every
single one of us when podcast started
were either great features or awesome
headliners and all of us had a podcast
you know and all of us told similar
story so it's almost like the Marvel
Universe where it's like hey if you want
to see spider-man and and this you know
by this other comic you know where they
would have those crossovers and that is
a lot of it like that when it comes to
this because people like cuz what people
always say when they come up to me is
like I'm a fan of punk but I also like
tinfoil hat and I like bill birnes
podcast and I like Kreischer and I like
you know they'll give me five or six
comics that they read that are all
connected in the same universe right you
know I mean no is that really read Ben
right that's a real red band somebody
asked me is that the real red band and I
go unfortunately you're walking right by
me is that the real red band I go
unfortunately
man these family so as for so hey is
there a show rate after us no Aaron said
we can go to 5:30 if you got to leave
you can't we're almost done I mean we're
gonna go a little over because I just
want to talk about real quick the NCAA
that's a guy just message us on Facebook
said he wants you to talk about any what
you think by Arizona about Arizona yeah
and yeah he's [ __ ] how do you not fire
him how do you not fire him got it doing
it but you know what man if I was him I
you know it's like hey man if you don't
think everybody's doing that I mean that
guy got one dude that rent
Duke's got three of coming in next year
do you really think these guys they're
all about cash going to the pros are
going to Duke because they they want to
be part of that legacy it's crazy I
heard that this is from two hours ago
Sean Miller met Monday with people from
Arizona so he's gonna learn his fate
yeah we know what his fate is he's got
his head on the chopping block
and axis on his way down and he coach
again I think he got he can go to some
little [ __ ] weird little spot
somewhere I mean he got [ __ ] you know
what he's gonna have to do he's he's
gonna have to go to the pros for a
little while that guy who's coaching
Houston right now Simmons Simpson he was
the guy who coached avi slappy Swanson
Samsonite he coached a couple he coached
a couple NCAA teams he got busted
cheatin so they kicked him out and right
back the guy who's the coach of
humanistic
or you talk about Mike D'Antoni no no I
think Hugh Stein are the Cougars of are
the NCAA's he went to the pros for a
while uh this whole scandal all killing
the Cohen Sampson yeah nobody dude this
isn't shocking we all know it's
happening and the only reason this is
going down you know what these kids are
you know what these kids are that are
getting bused for this they're like weed
dealers of like five ten years ago where
you like everybody's doing it everybody
knows about it now you know and then now
that's legal it's not a big deal
they should let these kids [ __ ] do
whatever they want how ahead of its time
was that [ __ ] movie blue chips that's
like exactly you
you are normally right exactly what's
happening out and said he got paid he
goes as soon as the you know I went to a
relatively small college or what the
Ball State University Duke rod and no
but I lived above a place above a and
all so there's like four apartments kind
of like where we used to be neighbors it
was like that up there and it was
football team football team football
team me and my alcoholic buddies so we'd
always play spades but all the buddies
Hugh Jason oh I wouldn't yes they were
there or you know but um and dude this
is so this is back then couple of them
went pro Bernie Parmalee few of them
played you know a little bit in the pros
the stuff that they got and the little
payouts that they got at a school of
twenty thousand that was it doesn't
matter insane you're just like oh
Alabama
Notre Dame the guy said he got a floor
and that story went away it's dude it's
just because people run the NCAA these
greedy old white dudes want to keep all
the cash they don't want to give and
it's not that much to pay every player
they had a loophole Indiana long
basketball they blew cost you about a
hundred eighty million dollars here now
you're like that's a lot of money not
when you think that they signed an eight
I think and this might just be with one
channel eight year eight billion dollar
[ __ ] deal so that does include
ticketing merchandise or anything like
that well the problem with that is and
then the argument that comes in is yeah
you could do that and football as well
sure does it that's a big one and they
believe me that they make a lot of money
in college football but then you go
what about they ain't got to pay all the
athletes so now what do you pay a female
volleyball player well they have emails
off welcome to your first life lesson if
you don't generate money none German you
don't get paid that's the conundrum they
get a billion dollars no they're from
March Madness now you know these ladies
you're 21 days there are billion dollars
in 21 days to make 1 billion dollars not
thing none of it goes to the athletes
your sport is only able to function at a
college because football and basketball
make so much
money they fund the rest of this that's
your payment that's true you're good to
go it's poor that nobody gives a [ __ ]
about right uh dude if nobody's like we
should have a if you generate if you
generate like a women's soccer though
the women's soccer team you say they
generate ratings they should get paid
they should get paid whatever they
should not get paid like a man no we
agree on that
yeah we are yeah I was thinking that
women had better ratings in soccer than
men but that's not what their argument
was not they don't I mean we looked it
up the last time we talked about it like
they didn't but they but it they should
get paid though in relation with what
they get paid yeah I mean what the
ratings are yeah see dude that should be
your podcast you just anybody or zero
that should be yeah it is it's called
punch strong yeah what woman sport is
more you're right though women's tennis
is that's the more entertaining the
men's tennis more equally as interesting
female I'm amazed really ah female MMA
I'm all in on Thema ten years
yeah well because it just started here's
the thing with female hours I've said
before on the show it's the sports that
the female sports have blow up are the
ones where two things happen they can
piggyback on the men's sports like
Wimbledon right or the UFC the those are
big sports because you're covering the
guys and the women get as much heat but
when they can combine their their sports
together hmm the sports that we're
that's not already established meaning
like the NBA baseball right the reason
the WNBA can't get any trash is because
they're competing with highlights from
Michael Jordan Blake Griffin all these
high-flying superstars and these girls
are doing layups
they should lower the rim man they
should lower the red man nine feet why
not I don't care yeah that would be
super entertaining if we started a
montage of mm-hmm
to me it's just like the athletic that
WNBA and and women's my mother had
season tickets to Notre Dame's women's
basketball which they are always in the
top three she goes to like you know
almost every game I've gone and and it
feels like I'm watching and it's my time
misogynist that feels like I'm watching
an high school basketball game or an
eighth grade game when I look with it
cuz I've gone to have been every NBA
Stadium I've seen so many pro games and
in college the only thing they can do is
shoot they can really shoot the ones
great you know a pick-and-roll is they
think and roll and everything fifty
Celtics basketball it's fine and that's
fine but I'm saying I don't care but I
watch women's tennis I am as excited as
I am watching men's do well they can get
volleys going it's almost better it's
incredibly competitive do you guys
remember slamball of course you know
that's back again is it bad yeah yeah I
actually really enjoyed slam its back on
the shots they would pull off yeah I
mean come on so fun go big yeah I always
say this I lower the rims and let these
girls don't have you dude yeah how much
of the Olympics have you guys been
perusing watching curling curling I
watched a lot of metal and I was a man
dude oh absolutely yeah the men curling
one of the greatest comebacks and I love
this that's what they should let the
women do to just have trampolines that
would no you know what I know it's
thinking about this you know what make
so you don't have to dribble at all once
you're on the trampolines it's just do
whatever you want with the ball yeah you
get two bounces and then you try to
score I like it weird though it's very
rare I like it though I'm telling you
that's what the XFL should do they
should try to come up with some crazy
[ __ ] trampolines like punch our
prediction coming in we're right about a
lot of things here comes mine the
highest-paid player in the access
fell will be tim tebow yeah hey Denis
should I mission my Vince young Robert
Savage a three second guess if they can
if they can't get Tebow away from
baseball Johnny Manziel for sure he's
got a criminal record you wouldn't let
anybody play a criminal oh yeah cuz that
guy's just been the straight and narrow
forever that guy I never done anything
dicey it's an All American League for
white people that's my take on the NTA
this is only happening because they're
greedy as [ __ ] and it's I hope the whole
thing burns down it's going I hope they
keep I hope programs get nailed it when
we all know comes out what we already
knew you're knocking these guys unless
you're playing dirty these guys don't
give a [ __ ] I need a mine early no
you're right a lot of high school right
well up dude I just think they need to
get we've our discusses that they need
to get rid of the amateur sports and
make it a semi-pro for NCAA because they
generate so much money for the
universities that they should just be
like they should make it [ __ ] a
little scratch everybody at that level
should that's because if you let the the
college you start playing people paying
people they're worried about oh I'm only
gonna go where I get paid more if
everybody gets paid then it's more than
legal balance yeah well you'll see
you'll see the other schools maybe then
then historically you know how you make
women's ass that's debate like it should
be just political debate with Jason
Tebow you know how you make women's
basketball more interesting land mines
no you know what about that Australia
has here that did do that here that Isis
has netball do you know what netball is
show your netball it's like basketball
right but it's just like it's like girls
in like they're hot chicks playing it
instead of like but it's a very lesbians
in that WNBA it's like basketball with
with hotle this is South Africa versus
they got that rap
that's like yep all mine
yeah Wow I already like it is absolutely
stunning miniskirts which is just silly
it's like those old Star Trek episodes
[Music]
to our video what's the prize oh I'm
trying to wake it to a highlight here we
go Oh looks like a basketball with no
rim that must be or no backboard
yeah what happened Oh think about how
often somebody has to go fetch the ball
so there we go and then they what they
jump the ball every time so you can't
dribble once you get the ball it's like
Ultimate Frisbee yeah yeah it's awesome
it frisbee basketball dig that with a
ball with like they're all just like a
hora from Star Trek yeah oh you can
bounce pass though all the rest are
doing what this is this is the best
thing what's the name so people at home
can watch smart ball ball and I actually
want to do curling I think that would be
a minnetonka video like three of us go
curling you know wanna start doing on
show and then we'll wrap it up is that I
want to do UFC live UFC a shows at the
oh I was all out of gig but I wanted to
come to that that sounded like it a bit
what a great idea ever
yeah what a great idea they show it for
free doesn't cost anything we just have
would you do like a like a UFC thing and
then maybe a punch book show afterwards
what Betty's oh yes yep I knew that I
want to get into that a lot of stuff
going on a lot of bets
I've been doing my parlays haven't hit
yet but I'm getting close I'm in close
close and yeah March Madness coming up
which by the way I got a 25 bucks bonus
turn it into $250 to get out like you -
thank you about this I thank you Betty I
go to bet Dias I use the promo code
punch 25 yep what does that get you
saying that get you 25 dollars betting
cash free money to gamble if double your
investment what I mean your yep your
initial put it you sure you put a 100
bucks in now you got 200 you know 25
bucks
boom 25 of those are from your good
friends here
showing hope you win uh March Madness
coming up you have C's always around
thank you for coming second favorite
really October's my favorite because it
means NCAA's I mean MBAs about star
except all the major sports are going
September flippers man would prefer the
beginning of the season to the end of
the season what kind of fan prefers the
beginning of the NBA season I just
because we have basketball forever okay
you know we don't suck yeah and then
we're gonna do our an NBA Summer League
trip we all go there we all go watch it
together in Vegas yeah
also hey the the QA for patreon that's
coming up okay yeah tweet us oh no it's
not sweet we put out a poll on the
patreon or a email thing and people send
us questions all right so that's our
show it's a little short today cuz
Bilborough had to go long and that's
fine
it's his network he can do whatever he
wants to he's looking shredded you know
anyone else nervous about him flying
helicopters I am are you really nervous
yeah when you're famous you should never
fly yourself like I'm like like it like
if I blow up and I'm like guys I got a
submarine you know it's like I'm about
two years away from going but belly up
dude you know what sucks about being a
conspiracy theorist is like 700 like I
was flying in the Vegas and the [ __ ]
plane was I'm like oh yeah plane gets
higher you [ __ ] Illuminati get yeah
yeah Southwest look up Southwest plane
the other day wait push all your social
media before you go sure follow me on
social media at Jeremiah's standup
Jeremiah Watkins TV and I'll be
co-headlining the la jolla Comedy Store
with red ban on March 8th so if you're
in the same the airline called a
performance issues happy for you you're
kicking LA you work really hard dude
thank you and I appreciate your your
grind and I everybody season I'm happy
that's starting to pay off for you so
that's really great thanks and I think
the future is very bright for you all
right guys that's been a punch-drunk
sports and we'll see you next week ma'am
we're winners
yeah look at this